what you're about to watch is a clip
from my brand lytics training where i
get together with entrepreneurs thought
leaders who want to build their brand
using youtube and making data driven
decisions to blow up their brand this
year
enjoy
we talked about going longer and this is
a relatively new thing
uh if you go back two years on youtube
even a year on youtube it wasn't as big
a deal as it is now inside of thought
leadership and it's super weird because
almost everybody else is going shorter
youtube shorts
youtube stories
instagram reels tick tock everybody's
going shorter
in thought leadership
it's like don't even worry about shorts
i haven't seen anybody win with shorts
we have two shorts channels i haven't
proven that that that it is worth your
time or investment i'm telling everybody
to go long go long long longer longer
ten minute minimum but go half an hour
go an hour go three hours if you're good
like if you know what you're talking
about if you can give a master class it
has a much better chance of helping you
build a channel and build a business
that you want as opposed to the really
short videos uh so
just a refresher back to the top
hashtag youtube belongs
says drew
uh
eddie posted this video this was his
challenge that we had after the last
month post a three-hour video
and he did
and because he posted to the group and
guys share your stuff in the group share
your win and share what you need help
with because you might get featured on a
future for analytics session you never
know
let's look at this video so i uh i was
on i as soon as eddie posted this and
like ooh let's see how it's doing let's
see how we're doing eddie i want this
video to win am is evan carmichael right
or not
does it work because eddie's also kind
of on the fringe of thought leadership
right it's not just a talking head or
coaching videos it's on the motivation
side
so
views are down
right
this is this is uh days so this video is
nine days old
and views are down and this is where
people freak out you know they look at
their one they're two days like oh my
god this video sucks like it's half of
what my usual the gray line represents
the usual this is what an average video
would do and the blue line represents
this specific video
uh so it's down but look hey it's
catching up it's catching up to our
average already this is actually pretty
fast
i would
i would say even within a month
suggested to get suggested to grow is
fast
i would be expecting typically in like
the 30 to 90 days where it starts to
take off and then over 90 days for sure
but if you're getting
it to start to catch up inside of the
first two weeks you're doing a really
good job so overall views are down okay
watch time whoo that's some nice watch
time look at that watch time that is a
delicious looking curve right that's
this video and this is his average so
he's already double his average watch
time in the first nine days
right so amazing amazing start
let's look at why
so
these two curves represent suggested is
the blue line and brows is the green
line and i looked at it yesterday and
browse was still
at the top just barely but today
got to check back in this morning to get
the most recent data suggested is at the
top
so you see browse is going it's good
it's decent and it's still climbing but
it's
this is what happens with brows like it
takes off at the beginning and then it
just slowly
keeps going hopefully and maybe you'll
get a pop every now and then because you
hit the home page but suggest that this
curve can keep going forever so already
inside of nine days suggests it has
passed
his brows
which is great
you look at the average view duration
and these numbers may be a little hard
to see but
i'll just read it out loud suggested 33
minutes
browse 16 minutes
that's how long people are watching
so in brows you're only watching for 16
minutes which is still great that's
still a good number
but they're watching for 33 minutes when
they come from suggested it's double
and that's why it's starting to take off
and you'll see that people
on the home page will have a much
shorter attention span this this should
go this should be repeated if you look
at your own everybody here you look at
your own channel stats look at the
average view duration
browse
versus suggested
it would shock me if browse was higher
suggested is always number one
so that's where we're gonna go because
youtube cares about watch time so we're
giving them lots and lots and lots of
watch time here
right
so even though the views are half
like the views are fifteen hundred
versus three thousand
the watch timer's already more
we're getting more watch hours from
suggested with half the views
this is a great video
i took a screenshot yesterday last night
this is this one and i took a screenshot
again this morning this is this one you
can see it's already it's picking up
it's already doing better and look at
the number one traffic source last night
suggested was 42 percent this morning
suggested is 48
suggested as number one this video has
an amazing future shelf life ahead of it
what's drew saying uh oh you have more
data from ben's channel yeah i mean
getting data is not
an issue there is tons i have tons of
data on this i want to share um not
ben's i wanted to share
uh
this one because hey eddie's in the
group
now the other thing that eddie was
really concerned about was well what if
i go
and upset my community
what if i upset the people
who are here who are used to my four
minutes seven minute ten minute videos
they don't they don't want a three hour
long video if you look at the comments
i haven't seen a nasty eddie this sucks
stop posting long videos right you're
awesome brother keep up the great work
you surely are shining your light in the
darkness of others so freaking good
thank you thank you so much bro this
compilation is absolutely amazing thank
you eddie for inspiring right
so the comments the the data is showing
us that it works but the qualitative
data with the comments is also
uh really helping us
now just as a quick comparison the next
video he launched was two days later and
was four
four minutes something
so three hours
the one we just looked at the next video
was four almost five minutes
i hate four or five minute videos inside
thought leadership
but let's look at a quick comparison to
see right so so far this one has more
views
the shorter one has more views
even though it came out two days later
the views are actually decent this is a
good video for him
right the gray line is average this is
our views and he's at the upper end of
his average for views which is great
the watch time though
is way below his average
and that may or may not catch up
the difference is here
we look at his real time i pulled this i
don't know 30 minutes ago
there's no suggested on this page
browse notifications channel
youtube search other features
so if suggested here it's less than five
percent this is a big problem so this
these kinds of videos put you on
the
the the
rat wheel is that a thing hamster wheel
the hamster wheel push on a hamster
wheel
thinking rat race and hamster wheel
combined becomes rat wheel this video
puts you on the rat wheel where you
basically have to keep making video
video video video video just to get the
short-term views but there's no
long-term sustainability on most of
these because
you can't rely on browse
notifications is going to go away
because notifications
it's only at the very very very
beginning of a video and with no
suggested it's going to go down and it
says i'm on the rat wheel
just coined a new term
uh
and also without you know diving deep
and sharing all revenue numbers for
eddie
this video is getting less than half
of the cpm so even though it has more
views right now short term out of the
data looks better this video is is going
to be a lot harder for him to get views
get subscribers and is making less than
half of the cpm on the video compared to
that three hour one that he just did
cool let me just share a couple examples
and we'll from from my top 10 channels
so
this is what we did here
now this is a newer thing right this is
an old video this is 500 days old
so the views this is an hour long video
where normally i'd be making you know 15
to 20 minute videos so it's hour 20
massively underperformed on the views
but now it's picking up on the views now
it's in the average of our views
the watch time was you know average but
now you know it's popping a lot harder
this one same thing 400 days old like
this is a relatively new thing
where youtube is really
showcasing promoting longer videos
i wouldn't have recommended the strategy
back here
400 days ago
but
past six months heck yeah
so views massively underperformed and
then boom took off
watch hours you can't even see the
average line it's you know it's tiny
there
this one took off
and if you just look at the traffic
sources you can see why right the the
blue line is suggested
the green line is browsed so as you get
more suggested it'll be recommended in
browse more too you'll see these often
brows can trail suggested but it's 69
coming from
suggested
so going along makes that huge huge huge
difference if you want to see this full
video as well as train live with me
twice a month to blow up your brand join
the brand linux training program there's
a link to join right there next to me
continue to believe i'll see you there